New York I'll kick your ass see if I
give a [ __ ] don't you guys know who
Andrew Tate is absolutely not absolutely
not why don't we like Andrew Tate isn't
it obvious I don't know I'm asking
people today quite a horrendous person
we love feminism and not him this is
Haram okay can you give me an example of
something that he said which is
anti-women he Advocates and like
recruits people to be against women's
rights basically does he can you tell me
more about this well do you want
examples I'll get my Google out I'd love
examples let's see let's see if we get
some examples of how Andrew Tate is
advocating a group of men to sort of
take away the rights of women well the
guardian says that Andrew Tate says
women belong in the home can't drive in
our man's property I'm no one's property
and anyone who thinks so can go [ __ ]
themselves I think he sort of means they
take care of a woman the same way he'd
take care of his other property like his
house his car it means he's going to
look after her isn't that quite nice I
mean being someone's property is not
nice because I don't belong to anyone I
can take care of myself thank you very
much you don't know man to take care of
you at all no no